Cómo ve usted este discurso que
sorpresas le trajo personalmente a usted
esta Este primer discurso del presidente
ante la asamblea nacional
Bueno pues muy buenas tardes En primer
lugar Feliz año para ti y para toda la
audiencia que nos escucha creo que bueno
en general está llegada esta vuelta de
Lula no esta tercera vuelta de Lula es
histórica por muchas razones y ha estado
marcada por varios símbolos no en lo que
respecta especialmente bueno su llegada
al congreso nacional no Lula optó por
realizar esta llegada eh A través de un
desfile no en el carro presidencial que
fue adquirido en la época del ex
presidente retulio Vargas en 1950 Y esto
es muy simbólico porque pues como
ustedes saben Brasil ha estado marcado
por una fuerte polarización continua
estandolo y hubieron amenazas de varios
tipos inclusive de bomba en este
contexto de la toma de Posesión
presidencial entonces Lula optó por
desfilar no más los controles de
seguridad que se hicieron entonces su
llegada al congreso de por sí fue
histórica fue recibido por la
expresidenta dimarusef por las
autoridades del Congreso Nacional y ha
dado un discurso también debería decir
histórico en muchos sentidos no yo creo
que es muy importante reconocer que este
regreso de Lula su retorno por la
tercera vez a la presidencia de la
República es Antes que todo el triunfo
de la Democracia sí El Triunfo de la
Democracia de las instituciones del
respeto a las reglas del juego sí Lula
fue elegido por más de 60 millones de
brasileños y está aquí para cumplir con
digamos su programa político no Entonces
en este sentido vale destacar que bueno
su discurso ha estado marcado por este
tipo de mensajes no lo afirmó de manera
recurrente no está aquí para representar
fortalecer y consolidar la democracia
está aquí como representante de una
amplia coalición que fue la que le
permitió llegar al poder sí está aquí
para como afirmó defender abiertamente
la democracia brasileña y al mismo
tiempo impulsar un modelo de desarrollo
que ponga digamos
que valorice que priorice la justicia
social sí los derechos de las mayorías
en este sentido se hablaron de varios
temas a lo largo de su discurso digamos
que tres de los puntos fundamentales
bueno han sido en primer lugar la
unificación sí del país frente a un
contexto amplio de polarización que que
es uno de los legados del gobierno
bolsonaro la unificación del país el
diálogo sí la reconstrucción de Brasil
ha sido uno de los temas también
prioritarios entonces a lo largo de su
discurso se han trabajado digamos todos
estos argumentos con explicaciones muy
claras de bueno que es lo que se va a
hacer en materia ambiental entonces
recuperar por ejemplo el liderazgo de
Brasil a nivel de lucha ante el cambio
climático y promoción de una transición
ecológica para digamos
un modelo de desarrollo que no deje de
lado las cuestiones ambientales las
preocupaciones ambientales que son de
primera orden a nivel global no Lula
también ha anunciado que Brasil está de
vuelta en lo que respecta claramente las
relaciones internacionales se habló de
integración regional se habló de retomar
los diálogos y el trabajo con el
mercosur retomar la integración regional
retomarla unasur Sí pero de manera
general Bueno lo que puedo decir es esto
no que Lula ha dado un discurso insisto
histórico valorizando el papel y la
importancia de la Democracia el papel y
el valor de las instituciones sí de los
valores republicanos esto es muy
importante y claramente ha hecho un
repaso un repaso histórico de Bueno lo
que ha sido el retorno a la democracia
de Brasil no lo afirmó en en algún
momento si durante la dictadura militar
se decía dictadura nunca más no estará
el lema Ahora hay que decir democracia
para siempre no Entonces me parece un
muy importante Sí luego claramente se
habló también de retomar en su proyecto
no la justicia social retomar las
inversiones sociales retomar las
políticas públicas
se ha establecido combatir
la digamos el hambre que afecta en estos
momentos a más de 30 millones de
brasileños si se habló también en su
discurso bueno de
algunas innovaciones que ha traído este
nuevo gobierno como una mayor
representatividad no de género por
ejemplo de su gobierno formado por 37
ministerios con un récord de mujeres 30%
de mujeres hay también cinco
representantes de los de las de la
ciudadanía afrodescendiente brasileña y
también por la primera vez se ha
establecido la creación de un Ministerio
de pueblos indígenas liderado por Sonia
guayayara una importantísima líder
indígena del país no Entonces a lo largo
de su discurso Lula Más allá de examinar
no lo nefasto que ha sido por ejemplo el
gobierno bolsonaro en muchos sentidos
también explicó un poco estos estos
cambios estas innovaciones que se han
dado y qué es lo que buscan realizar que
es lo que buscan obtener
pensando en la reconstrucción justamente
del país
María él hablaba en su discurso de
varias reformas una reforma laboral
también una reorganización institucional
inclusive una reversión de esa
flexibilización del uso de armas que
ocurrió durante el gobierno de Jair
bolsonaro cómo va a ser Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva para desarrollar todas
estas reformas y para sacarlas adelante
con un congreso en el que no tiene
mayoría en el que su partido no tiene
mayoría y en el que gran parte más de la
mitad o alrededor de la mitad está con
la derecha
Sí mira creo que hay varios factores
aquí uno de ellos es reconocer algunas
cualidades de Lula como gran líder
histórico
político aquí en Brasil para América
Latina a nivel internacional esto es
reconocido Más allá de la postura
política que se pueda tener es una gran
figura política y bueno una de sus
características principales y su
capacidad de conciliación de diálogo y
conciliación sí esto en lo que respecta
a la figura de Lula da Silva Más allá de
esto como comenté al inicio de mi
intervención Este es un gobierno
diferente si es un tercer gobierno de
Lula pero es un gobierno diferente
porque es un gobierno de coalición sí
hay que recordar que el actual
vicepresidente Gerardo alkimi es un
adversario histórico de Lula sí
representante ahí de la socialdemocracia
brasileña composiciones más bien de
bueno centro derecha no en en materia
sobre todo económica etcétera entonces
no es un gobierno puramente sí Entonces
es gobierno ahí marcado por un
importante diálogo Sí más Más allá de
esto Lula ha obtenido Lula y este
gobierno no de manera general sus
primeras victorias ya con lo que se
llama cada lapec la propuesta de
enmienda constitucional de la transición
no lo que se hizo así que apenas Lula
cuando tuvo la victoria fue crear un
grupo de transición que evaluó lo que ha
sido el legado del gobierno bolsonaro
emitió un informe en el que se realiza
un amplio estudio un amplio análisis no
de lo que ha sido el Gobierno bolsonaro
delegado que deja para el país en
diversas áreas y bueno se optó por
establecer a partir de allí una
propuesta que permita abordar los gastos
de los próximos años y retomar este
proceso de construcción del país que
Lula ha prometido no Esto se está
haciendo con mucho diálogo por supuesto
No será fácil esto es importante
mencionarlo no será nada fácil pero creo
que hay buenas expectativas en mi país
justamente por
bueno todo lo que ha significado el
gobierno bolsonaro hay una capacidad de
trabajo conjunto Sí Más allá de las
diferencias de parte de muchos actores y
creo que bueno hay hay esperanza de que
se pueda de que se pueda llevar a cabo
María quizás uno de los puntos más
importantes que ha tocado el presidente
Lula da Silva ha sido lo de sacar de la
pobreza 33 millones de personas del
hambre a 33 millones de personas otras
100 millones de personas se estima que
viven sobre el por debajo de la línea de
pobreza qué tiene que hacer el gobierno
del para para poder cumplir este
objetivo en un escenario que en este
momento es bastante difícil en donde
estamos
Acabamos de salir de una pandemia
adicionalmente está una guerra en
Ucrania llevándose a cabo tenemos una
inflación altísima en todo el mundo cómo
va a ser el para solucionar todos estos
inconvenientes en medio de un panorama
tan difícil
sí esto que mencionas es muy importante
no se ha dicho por ahí lo lo dijo Lula
ya en su primer discurso tras la
victoria no Brasil está de vuelta
anunciando justamente que Brasil retoma
no el protagonismo en las relaciones
internacionales A diferencia de lo que
ocurrió en el país durante el gobierno
bolsonaro que estuvo marcado por un
amplio aislamiento internacional sí
sin embargo claramente estamos en un
nuevo escenario Brasil no es el mismo y
el mundo no es el mismo Sí entonces
claramente habrán dificultades habrán
adversidades pero en relación a esto que
mencionas específicamente que es el
combate al hambre en Brasil tiene una
trayectoria histórica y resultados
importantísimos hay que recordar que
Brasil logró implementar programas
Pioneros de combate al hambre que se
convirtieron En referencia internacional
entonces existe capacidad técnica existe
capacidad existen recursos humanos
existe voluntad política y es muy
probable porque hay un compromiso por
parte del gobierno que es un gobierno
como ya mencioné antes de coalición
amplio en el que esto se logre sí
insisto también con esto no será fácil
pero me parece que esta Va a ser una
prioridad en la medida en que Bueno
estamos hablando de una emergencia
social no estamos hablando de ciudadanos
que no pueden alimentarse correctamente
Y eso es es un problema para el país es
un problema de ciudadanía es un problema
también a nivel económico porque es un
problema que dificulta el desarrollo del
país entonces la medida en que hay una
comprensión sobre lo que esto significa
en la medida en que ya existe también
una experiencia de que Brasil fue capaz
de hacerlo y hay recursos hay
conocimiento y voluntad Creo que será
probable que se logre